Richie sunac 60
399 Liz truss 81
326. therefore I give notice that Liz
truss is elected as the leader of the
conservative and unionist party
the result had been widely predicted but
it's no less significant given the
candidate's differing approaches on the
economy and helping people facing huge
rises in energy bills
Liz truss addressed those issues but
only after a tribute to the man she
replaces as prime minister on Tuesday
Boris you got brexit done you crushed
Jeremy corbyn you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to Vladimir Putin
you were admired from Kiev to Carlisle
Rishi sunak resigned along with dozens
of conservative MPS accelerating Boris
Johnson's departure he's now urged
Tories to unite behind his former
cabinet colleague but she knows winning
back public trust will be a big
challenge
after such a long selection process the
urgency for the new prime minister to
tell the public exactly what steps
they'll be taking over the cost of
living crisis is clear and let's trust
khans have failed to realize that a lot
of the work I think has been done and I
think the team are aware that once you
transition from campaigning to
government this is the top question on
people's minds and people will expect to
hear clear and comprehensive answers and
I think we'll get that later this week
I will deliver on the energy crisis
dealing with people's energy bills but
also dealing with the long-term issues
we have on energy Supply
after previously focusing on tax cuts
trusses reportedly considering a freeze
on energy bills something the opposition
labor party has called for there's a
political consensus that needs to happen
she needs to answer the question how she
going to pay for that laboring me clear
there needs to be a windfall tax on oil
and gas companies so she needs to show
that she actually understands and commit
the challenges that are there after 12
years of failure of this Tory government
and we will deliver a great victory for
the conservative party in
2024. thank you thank you so no shortage
of immense challenges so immense in fact
that some predict another leadership
challenge before the next election is
due in two years time Nadine barber Al
Jazeera London